this man is gonna be at The Improv
tonight in Irvine California before
heading to Sacramento the punch line at
Sacramento and Cobbs comedy club in the
beautiful Bay Area in San Francisco he
is Frank Caliendo good to see you Frank
great to be here in your presence I
appreciate that yeah let's talk well you
wanted to talk ping-pong I don't want to
it's just what everybody wants me to
talk about because I'm so great at
you're at you're great at the great at
it's Table Tennis yeah the ping pong is
you know that's a it's a name brand it
is like q-tip a band-aid band-aid is
another one's lyrics Xerox Kleenex Rich
Eisen show but yeah I play and then
whenever they interview me they always
like can you play ping pong as Morgan
Freeman well that's when I realize that
ball came too fast at it but it's it's
embarrassing because you play in these
tournaments I play not you you're not
playing yet I'm gonna get you involved
okay
USA TT United States Association table
tennis I think or something
AT&T maybe I don't know I get emails
from both of them but you play and then
you'll play like a 12 year old kid and
the kid will just destroy me hmm right
and then the dad knows who I am
so they want to take a picture with me
so it's like the kid holding up a fish
and I'm the fish right so it's just the
worst cuz you get beat by it like just
every your your machismo your takes a
hit it's just destroyed takes as these
kids are so their hands their hands are
over the table but I understand Frank
that people want you on their show or be
around you say can you can you do X as
absolutely but people want you to play
table tennis
everybody that's everything who's the
most difficult person to play table
tennis as well try I think that's a good
question I only ask those - yeah you're
nailing I'm too happy Bill Walton
because he never had ready for the
greatest serve of all time is the
verse succeeds itself and we understand
thinness is sitting there we can't give
away too many spoilers but understand
there seems to be some sort of deceptive
practice going on in this world
I sent Bill Walton email yes ah cuz I I
have a friend his son is a basketball
player he's about to be like a known
everywhere he's a 14 year old his name
is Shakeel son no his name is Dylan
Anderson he's 610 he's 14 geez and he
moves like a high school six three good
you know guard everything it's
ridiculous but so what was it was a bit
the Bill Walton you know wise like Bill
you got to meet this kid because they
you know just you're tall too right so I
try to hook up tall people so they can
meet each other because I'm never gonna
be a part of that so and the email he
sends back you were my friend will
always be like it's nothing he didn't
answer any questions I'm telling you
literally you have it oh yeah yeah yeah
it's really good for radio stuff this
this segment where Frank narrates as
Jeff Goldblum oh hi yes trying to figure
out where they'll all turn is I was in
Thor or that yes is that what I was in I
believe so oh I just looked up the wrong
thing I looked up walk Christopher
Walken Wow
oh wow everybody does that one Bill
Walton okay here's here's his answer to
me I go there's kid from Arizona when
she meets 6 10 14 years old size 19 shoe
size this way goes yes anything for you
forever we're in downtown San Diego it's
a big place how can I help
I love all things you thanks for my life
BW like I asked him where I used to San
Diego still yes anything for you forever
and here's he puts the commas in these
places yes comma anything for you
forever comma we're it's a haiku I think
now that 575 is that what seven five
seven it depends on what universe you're
from well I mean hold on I'm checking
emails
and checking emails update what man look
at these emails we're not gonna use any
of that GPS that was one of my favorite
things they're talking about technology
at his first press conference we're not
gonna be using technology man we're not
gonna be using GPS or video tape or word
processors man we're gonna go back to
tackling teach these K these kids how to
brush their teeth you know go to circle
man floss form a seat you ever see those
infomercials in your kid man tell you
what that's some good stuff right there
look like I'm trying to lay an egg yeah
you did say that we're gonna we gonna
eat
GPS you back where you pull back we're
good you know we're gonna we're gonna
yeah you know Bill Belichick you know
that guy is man they got a couple tight
ends they started doing teeth I'm doing
three full bags one for full backs man
yeah
we're gonna get rid of we're gonna even
have an offensive lion anymore we're
gonna change we're gonna look at the
rules how do you think Rudin is sitting
there now in front of all of his nude
players did you think this is different
this games really change
well lecturing them on how to be better
on social media or be careful that's uh
what so let's keep to ourselves don't
use any that GPS so I did a Vista this
is a actually good story it makes sense
okay I perform finally part of us so I
performed for the owners at the NFL at
the Superbowl that's the one of the
toughest gigs hardest like Jim Gaffigan
is done it al Madrigal is done it we've
interviewed them all very hard they do
know I'm impossible because you try to
relate to an NFL owner like you'd be
like hey anybody ever go to Walmart I
own the competition what are you gonna
do
they don't do the same things than any
of us do not even close
right so Goodell Roger uh you know who
he is right Roger Goodell if he's the
Commissioner the NFL and he's he's in
the front and I say I in 15 years of
being on all the sports NFL stuff I've
never done a Roger Goodell impression
and he looked at me and I'm like I'm not
gonna and I'm not gonna start today and
it the relief on his face he stood up
gave me a standing ovation and I had
like 50 different like kind of you know
protest kind of jokes that I didn't do
because I hadn't been paid yet I was
like I just stayed out of that but then
so I went to the Gruden stuff and Mark
Davis is sitting back in my left corner
there right because there's you flip it
when the audience is looking at you nice
so I just like to set the scene so one
that's 1 out of 12 I got it's a laugh
that's good enough for me so I'm doing
some Gruden stuff and I go to apologize
to Mark Davis afterward I'm like cuz I'm
messing with him a little bit he was
super nice about it I'm like sorry is
being such a dork and he's like can you
believe I gave Jon Gruden ten million
dollars a year car salesman I was like
what are you doing is like 10 million
dollars a year what was they thinkin
that's nuts
ooh I'm like no what tell me more you
said you got to come out and do some Jon
Gruden for us I'm like how much you pay
10 million crazy he was super nice
though it was fun and then I try to talk
to Jerry Jones and Jerry Jones always
seemed like he had something better to
do and not talk to me so I'd walk over I
come about that close from Jerry Jones
and all of a sudden you'd see this so I
believe that we did not have time for a
turn in the Birman believe me my newest
thing cuz I do
Mel Kiper jr. just yelling Todd shannon
sharpe saying skip and the thought pops
cube thoughts kill Todd
thought thought skip the part skip top
top skill taught thoughts are thought I
should have had gum for the segment
that's okay it's okay I'll swallow it
here's what I want to do I'm gonna take
a break we have come up with Berman
nickname I tell you what man I can't
wait to see some of those you use those
on the dot matrix printer that's we're
doing Todd we're going back we're doing
an Amiga computer man Atari play that
Three Stooges a video game we're gonna
play pong man forget for tonight
I don't care about tilted towers we've
got some bourbon nicknames have some
freshly drafted player he don't want you
to I want you to do your you do your
best not doing any voices next segment
that's an odd thing Frank Caliendo we're
on the Rich Eisen show we're back with
160 seconds
Frank Caliendo on a couple of weeks
Thursday May 10th at the wise guy at the
gateway in Salt Lake City Monday May
28th the punchline in Atlanta Georgia
Zane's Inez in Nashville Tuesday May
29th and Wednesday May 30th at the DC
improv I've heard Nashville by the way
is a spot word that might get the end of
the NFL Draft next year that might be
the next month oh really I don't know
you're on the inside on some of it I'm a
little bit it's amazing I'd like to see
all the way inside I'm on the periphery
of it yeah to stay there cool I'm in
between inside and outside whatever the
hell that is
I know that's the Phantom's the fact I'm
with General Zod just going to freak
yeah oh yeah I was just with my family
we were in uh in Paris we were in the
Eiffel Tower and that's all I could
think of was the first scene of Superman
- that's honestly that's all I was
thinking about that's because I was with
my family in the Phantom Zone and all I
could think about was being here with
you slightly on the inside I tell you I
didn't tell you so I and forth a steep
climb because I'm that kind of guy
general manager of the Arizona Cardinals
yes um we're good pals and you're his
son plays on my flag football team we've
actually let his son Warner he was our
offensive coordinator yes we can you
just pointed to place but dude fun and
we would do it he's like that wasn't it
like well you're five you are the coach
of a five year old flag phone no no no
no I play on the team yeah no I my son
plays it's 12-under cuz Carson you know
Steve's kids are all named after
quarterbacks right Larson Brady and
Warner I'm so I really outside see now
you're inside really oh you didn't know
that it's Carson Brady and Warner my
daughter Sloan I don't know I guess it's
better than Spurgeon right oh yeah I'm
all after Cleveland Browns now couch yes
Quinn so we just
Warner just kind of hangs around yeah
and he just wanted to call the place so
we gave him the place sheet and he
started just calling him so any they
have a great job we want uh-huh so I'm
Owen for he's
want to know is the OSI you were out man
but yes but but Steve said that you are
the inspiration for their draft that you
that you know actually that right there
my running yeah they usually have a
photograph of me running up on their
draft board and they'll usually have it
up when they know they're on camera on
the NFL Network
so you're I think I do it all the time
you're really right that's odd
oh yeah he took after they picked Josh
Rose and I was like nice I text him I
text him during the draft just to see if
I was important enough to get a text
back did you get one I got some yes you
I was so he's like you're my guy I'm
like you haven't because he stresses so
much during everything if you watched
I'm like he's just yeah so are you
saying that if I'm on the draft board as
much as I am
was that the inspiration for them to
draft a Jewish player is that what
you're saying yeah you started something
special look at me yeah you know I like
it I have here on my this card is like
the first time I saw spider through
Frank Kelly I knew I have a card here
with Berman in my in my in my in my
right hand I have car a card of Berman
nicknames of for the current drafted top
players and Blake I you have not seen it
before you now have it yeah yeah that we
have the number one pick what surprised
you letter P I back say what you will
about being six foot four taller again
been in this case Baker Mayfield some
gold
he made fields of I gotta work on date
that day Annunciation Josh and we are
living here in Allentown that's a
stretch even for me at quittin Nelson T
favorite quit Nelson T Reilly yeah quit
Nelson T I'm having trouble here with
somebody broke Juan Smith and West
yeah what way Mike pastor I probably
should have looked at these at it bad
pass the put clency analytics Josh every
Rosen has its thorns it's doing Gary
dang big uh sake wine don't call them
Charles Barkley me terrible where did
that come from me living in my
epiglottis by the way epiglottis sounds
like it would be great chef tour word
don't you think epiglottis turns out
that there is a problem with his
epiglottis but it seems that the
epidural hematoma aroma it's the smell
coming from the epiglottis
which is plural for epiglottis cousin up
the platypus it's a platypus stuck
inside your neck somewhere that's how
that's how shefter does it though like
he will just talk in little segments
until you it seems to be a definite
possibility there's a chance probability
says he's the one he's one of the guys
every time I do shefter he's like listen
I I get it but I just don't think it
sounds like me I don't have the honesty
he doesn't he's like I hear what Bradley
Chubby Checker the last one is my
favorite one you're on major pain wait
what now matt damon wayans yeah
incredible annette major
oh gosh
so shefter does not think it sounds like
him no a lot of people don't think of
they sound like it's right Maddon right
yeah you're gonna never liked it I told
this story that I made us I made his
grandkids laugh and it was like no
Gruden's had fun with it right Steven a
have you ever done Steve oh of course I
have you have to understand what's going
on here mister Iseman Rich Eisen yeah
what would Steven ace that's perfunctory
let me ask you I personally don't know
it for fun to me Chris Brockman takes
his shoes off on a plane which I have a
problem with we don't have to say that
there that that is the opposite of
aromatherapy right there oh my gosh
Frank Caliendo you are a gem sir
I'm a treat you are that perfunctory is
an action carried out with minimum
effort what I did on the show today I am
perfunctory I will not by the way it
will stick with me the rest of the day
hearing Adam Schefter say the word
epiglottis if a platypus I'm gonna think
of a children's nursery rhyme that would
be we did that with like Liam Neeson
like I was doing a radio show Nordyke
doing Liam Neeson like there was an old
woman who lived in a shoe she had so
many children she didn't know what to do
because they'd been taken I never
understand how they could keep doing
taken movies don't you think it's
something maybe he's in he's on a cell
phone now it doesn't even make the movie
all the time but there's always like a
cell phone I don't know who you are I
don't know what you want if you're
looking for me to take a short survey I
can tell you this I don't have the time
what I do have are a very particular set
of skills skills that make me a
nightmare for people like you and if you
don't hang up right now I will find you
I will hunt you down and and that's when
the caller realize they should have
called Morgan Freeman's house
at Frank Caliendo on Twitter again if
you are in Southern California tonight
the Irvine improv Tuesday tonight and
then the punchline in Sacramento
tomorrow Wednesday and then Thursday
Cobbs comedy club and all of them all of
them I'm doing a bunch of shows it's all
on Frank on stage calm okay and it's all
over the country and a lot of it is I'm
doing the impressions and stuff I've
known for but it's I'm trying to be
looser and try to write a lot of new
stuff while I'm out there so it's doing
smaller venues having fun excellent yeah
like this I'll be praying about this
many people there tonight 12 what you
didn't finish writing the bit yeah no no
I I'm just turning into noir McDonald
there you go yeah you're gonna the
grocery store he's the best just talking
about nothing ancillary I think you're
just saying hey you ever buy a tube of
toothpaste never do that your breath is
better after it yeah yeah so that's what
I really do appreciate is this mine that
is yours yours to keep to if you want it
if you don't love I can't get this on a
flight you know Frank a you're not on
the Rich Eisen show at Frank Caliendo on
Twitter always great to see you but
thank you for having you about the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience